rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
continuer la découverte des îles est de
mafate l'eba deuxième partie dilate à
malheur à grand-place
pour votre santé parcourez nos sentiers
en plein coeur de la partie basse de
mafate il est à mahler est un élève
jumeaux d'horaires duquel il est séparé
que par le bras b mal autrefois partie
intégrante d'horaires il est à mahler
tient son nom du massacre qui a eu lieu
sur son plateau en 1829 d'une
quarantaine d'esclaves par un
détachement de chasseurs de marrons une
page douloureuse de l'histoire du
marronnage à l'origine du peuplement du
cirque le premier peuplement véritable
c'était évidemment les promener les
marrons il est vraiment le on va dire ce
mafate de journy qu'on connaît ces
peuples et s'est développée à partir des
premiers colons premier blanc en fait
propriétaire qui était monté dans le
cirque c'était nicolas lemarchand 1783
c'est lui qui a lancé la tendance de
défricher les les forêts à l'époque il y
avait sur les plateaux pour mettre en
culture en fait la clé turbo milliards
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les gens font
toujours tout le monde a toujours son
lopin de terre avec ce maïs dessus ces
haricots
saleh dans le temps quoi
à la sortie de l'île est la traversée
d'une ravine couvert de filao conduit
directement l'intersection avec le
sentier scout la plaque qui porte ce nom
car c'est ici qu'on aurait été installé
la première signalétique du cir
la descente dans la grande ravine et la
première difficulté de cette randonnée
200 m de dénivelé positif et négatif
pour gagner 100 mètres à vol d'oiseau
une véritable frontière naturelle
la grande ravine à porte bien son nom
parce que justement c'est une mutation
naturelle comme assez assez importante
il est à mahler et il est à bours et
justement auparavant il est à bours
appartenait au domaine d'horreur le
marchand à l'époque c'est assez 17 cette
partie là un autre propriétaire parce
que c'était un peu trop loin et un peu
trop
il ya un peu trop difficultés pour pour
les récoltes en fête
après la remontée sur l'autre flanc de
la rabine les fils hao marque arrivée
sur le plateau d'i la bourse ces arbres
vieillissants vont être peu à peu
remplacé par le n f par des espèces
indigènes
plus présents corps de lille est une
autre parcelle devrait servir
prochainement et une association locale
pour l'utilisation de ces espèces en
tisanerie
mais
souvent plus lieu de passage que d'état
pour les randonneurs lille est à bours
mérite pourtant le détour depuis
quelques années ces habitants ont décidé
de jouer la carte du traditionnel en
réhabilitant des cases en paille à kehl
en paille en fait c'est le bâtiment
traditionnel qui se faisait un peu dans
mafate avant et avant 1959 avant 1980
parce que c'est vraiment l'hélico qui a
fait changer en fait l'aspect des
bâtiments dans les cirques en fait des
maisons généralement c'était du bois de
forêt qu'ils allaient récupérer dans les
forêts aux alentours et il tentait du
vétiver quitterais c'est qu'ils
mettaient sur les toits cette pratique
là est un peu en perdition parce que par
rapport aux nouveaux matériaux par
rapport aux cyclones pour s'abriter
c'est plus que la même chose mais quand
même une volonté des habitants de
ramener ça au bout du bout du jour pour
justement pour que tout le monde puisse
un peu voir un peu comment on vivait
auparavant
en plein coeur de lille est il est aussi
possible d'aller jeter un oeil à ce
magnifique affiche 8 m de circonférence
pour une hauteur supérieure à 20 mètres
un spécimen rare à la fois par sa taille
et par sa localisation dans une partie
de l'île où il en reste peu
qui t il à ta bourse est encore
traversée une ravine
plus large que la grande ravine le brad
ou s'ils n'en est pas moins pentu
c'est un
à l'arrivée à bord picard la vue dégagée
permettent une belle lecture de paysage
c'est là qu'on voit le mieux en fait le
plateau dileita bourses sont étendus tu
vois on voit bien qu'en fait c'est un
grand plateau qui va même jusqu'à on
voit même il est à malheur les eaux et à
50 60 ans en fait c'est toute là zone où
tout le plateau était cultivé il y avait
deux mille cinq cents habitants dans le
cirque et après le cyclone de 48 qui a
tout dévasté en fait la lessive est
lessivé mafate totalement parce qu'elle
est plus de racines qui ont retenu le
sol ben les lois 9 à l'époque les eaux
forêts ont replanté les fils hao qu'on
voit aujourd'hui en fait sur le plateau
une courte remontée permet de rejoindre
le col qui surplombe la partie haute de
grand place contrairement aux idées
reçues grand place à lille est le plus
grand et le plus peuplé de mafate juste
devant la nouvelle
corey
tiens
le long des sentiers qui traversent il
est ont été plantés de nombreux arbres
fruitiers dans la partie basse de l'île
est c'est l'école et la boutique de
l'ancien facteur qui matérialise la fin
de notre randonnée
ce sentier là qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
c'est un peu mon quotidien quoi c'est à
dire au moins une fois tous les to les
semaines je suis dessus et pour
justement l'une des facettes de mon
métier j'accompagne les gens dans leurs
projets so d'habitation soir projet
touristique dès lors où on rentre dans
les îles est sonné un peu curieux en
parlant après les gîtes heures ou en
parlant avec des habitants on peut se
rendre compte que ma face et pas
seulement des paysages magnifiques qui
s'est pas seulement de la nature mais
bien le côté humain
peuplement fait qui ressort basse que
j'aime un peu moins en fait sur cette
randonnée c'est évidemment et les deux
grande ravine en fait la grande ravine
elle même et la ravine brad aussi qui
qui demande quand même un peu un peu
d'effort physique rien à surmontable
mais quand même prévoir de l'eau peut
voir ce qu'il faut pour pour la
randonnée